President Trump said sat side by side
overnight with the controversial
President of the Philippines and said
they have a great relationship Rodrigo
Duterte is accused of human rights
violation during a bloody drug war in
his country mr. Trump dodged reporters
questions President Trump is being
criticized at home for his weekend
defense of Russian President Vladimir
Putin the president said Putin
personally denied again that he was any
part of interference in the u.s.
election in the president's words quote
he said he absolutely did not meddle in
our election and mr. Trump said this I
really believe that when he tells me
that he means it
Margaret Brennan is traveling with the
president she's in Manila that's capital
the Philippines where he's attending a
summit of Southeast Asian leaders
Margaret good morning good morning
during this five nation tour the
president has not spoken at all about
democratic values such as protecting
human rights and that silence seemed
particularly loud today when he met with
the president of the Philippines who's
been accused of sanctioning the killing
of thousands right over left in 1 2 & 3
the president's day began with an
awkward handshake with the controversial
president of the Philippines Rodrigo
Duterte and other world leaders we've
had a great relationship this has been
very successful after one-on-one meeting
President Trump boasted of his warm
rapport with duterte someone he's
praised for a brutal drug crackdown
largely enforced through extrajudicial
killings more than 6,000 suspected drug
dealers and users were murdered during
the first eight months of doterra taste
term according to the US State
Department Human Rights Watch says that
number has since climbed to 12,000
journalists and activists have also been
targeted due tear day has openly touted
personally murdering people just days
ago he bragged about fatally stabbing a
person as a teenager today in Manila the
two leaders ignored shouted questions
about human rights abuses the president
was also silent about human rights
violations during his stops in China and
Vietnam I think he's giving Putin a pass
for murder in Washington Obama era
intelligence
directors criticize the president for
arguing Russian President Vladimir Putin
was sincere when he again denied
interfering in the 2016 election I
believe that he feels that he and Russia
did not meddle in the election former
intelligence director James clapper I do
think both the Chinese the Russians
think they can play him US intelligence
concluded with confidence that the
hacking was directed by Russia at the
very highest levels on Sunday the
president tried to clarify as to whether
I believe it or not I'm with our
agencies especially as currently
constituted with their leadership as for
human rights the White House said they
briefly came up during a conversation
about the drug war but president duterte
spokesman said issue didn't come up at
all and that mr. Trump praised his war
on drugs Nora all right Margaret Brennan
in Manila murder thank you so much